music's biggest night happening right
here in las vegas of course we are
talking about the grammy awards the show
happens on sunday but it's already taken
over our city tonight the organization
music cares rolled out the red carpet
for its premiere and in-person year gala
at mgm grand garden sasha loftis takes
us there
tonight is really the start of the
biggest weekend in music and of course a
big weekend here in las vegas many we
spoke with tonight say they're grateful
to have the music cares gala and the
grammys here in our city great to be
back in vegas music's biggest weekend is
kicking off right here in las vegas
big name stars descended on mgm grand
friday for the music cares person of the
year gala honoring legendary singer and
songwriter joni mitchell it's hard to
make a living in music right and things
like covid make it really difficult for
a lot of people and music here is really
acts the event gives those who've made
it the chance to give back by raising
money for crucial services like medical
and dental care housing and even rehab
and recovery for people still trying to
find their footing oftentimes people
think of just the artists on stage but
there's hundreds even thousands on big
tours people who work behind the scenes
of music as well and as everyone here
looks forward to the grammys on sunday
they told us they're happy to see this
all happening here for me this is going
full circle and a new beginning and no
better way to do it than right here in
las vegas in this entirely new era for
the entertainment capital of the world
the many we spoke with were also
grateful for the music cares foundation
through the kovit 19 pandemic and
shutdowns of course the music industry
was very hard hit over the last two
years they also said it was a great
opportunity to really get back together
in person again reporting from mgm grand
tonight sasha loftis live local now